Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain an American science
fiction action film called “Logan's Run.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set in the year 2274.
The world has been torn down by a holocaust and
the surviving humans live in a utopian domed city.
The city inhabits an idyllic society where
there is little to no work and people are
free to pursue all of the pleasures of life. The
residents of the city are governed by computerized
servo-mechanisms and there are no human leaders.
The computer takes care of all aspects of life,
including reproduction, as no humans are allowed
to reproduce sexually. However, there is a catch;
a person can only live up to thirty years of
age before undergoing the rite of "Carrousel"
and being terminated. The computerized
Servo-mechanisms enforced this rule to manage
the population and keep it constant. But they
have made the residents believe that the people
who are terminated in the Carrousel are actually
“renewed” and brought back to life as babies.
Some people called the runners have caught up
to the fact that they are being lied to by the
computers. To stop them from running away from
the city, elite policemen called the sandmen
are appointed. To track people’s age, each
person is implanted with a "life-clock" crystal
in the palm of the left hand at birth. The life
clock changes color as they get older and begins
blinking as they approach their "Last Day.” The
protagonist of the movie is a sandman named Logan
5, but unlike the usual sandmen, he is curious
and questioning in nature. In the opening scene,
Logan 5 is in a laboratory looking at artificially
born infants. One of them is named Logan 6, who
he donated sperm for. His friend and colleague,
Francis 7 brings him out and takes him to that
month’s Carrousel event. Several people who
have reached the age of thirty are going to be
terminated and a crowd has gathered to witness the
rite. It is noticeable that the people are wearing
either red, yellow or green clothes, indicating
their ages, red; for the older ones, green is for
the middle aged and yellow is for the teenagers.
The sandmen wear their usual black uniform.
At the beginning of the ceremony, some masked
people in white gowns are brought to the arena
and circled around a giant lotus. Following that,
the platform they are on begins to move around
creating a zero gravity zone. The masked people
float in the air and are killed one after another
as the crowd cheers. When the rite is almost
over, the sandmen are alerted about a runner
trying to escape from the west entrance. They
chase him across the facility and eventually
shoot him off a balcony. Logan 5 scans the
man’s face and does a quick identity check.
Before leaving, he confiscates the runner’s
belongings that include a small metal ankh.
The abandoned dead body is then vaporized by a
modern device. Logan 5 is confused why the man
didn’t renew instead of trying to run away
but his friend Francis 7 dismisses it. The
sandmen are given lavish apartments and are
considered the elites of the new society.
Logan 7 is in his apartment drinking at the end of
the day. By pressing a button, he summons a girl
for his pleasure. The girl is named Jessica
6 and is fascinated by Logan’s apartment.
He gets her to the sofa and tries to kiss her,
but Jessica rejects him. She doesn’t want to get
close to him because she is grieving the death
of a friend who was terminated that day. Logan
dismisses her concerns stating that her friend was
just renewed, but Jessica scoffs at the comment,
claiming that Carrousels are deaths, not renewals.
Logan gets suspicious of her being a runner and
inquires about her age. Jessica quickly proves
that she is young by showing him her life clock
that hasn’t turned red yet. They are interrupted
by Francis who arrives with two girls in his arms,
looking to have fun. Jessica quickly
rushes out of the apartment saying
that she shouldn’t have been summoned.
The following day, Logan goes to the sandmen
headquarters to report the confiscated objects
from yesterday. There, he finds out that the
ankh is a special key that the runners use to
get to their secret hiding place called the
Sanctuary. The computer informs him that over
one thousand runners are on loose currently
and instructs him to catch them all. A confused
Logan asks the computer how many of the runners
have been renewed. He begins to suspect that the
renewal program is fraud when the computer doesn’t
answer. Instead, it orders Logan to be a runner
in disguise and help them catch the others. He
retaliates again, claiming that the life clock
on his palm will give away the disguise. To his
surprise, the computer removes his remaining four
years of life so people would believe he is a
runner. Logan protests but it goes in vain because
the computer turns itself off. Now he only has
some days to live and a mission in his hands.
He returns home and summons Jessica again,
believing that she knows something about running.
He tells her he has only some days to live and
shows her the ankh that is identical to the one
she is wearing around her neck. Jessica accuses
him of killing a runner for the ankh and storms
out, believing that Logan is setting up some
kind of trap. It is revealed that she is a part
of the runner group herself when she tells her
friends that Logan knows about the Sanctuary. They
order Jessica to finish Logan once and for all.
She brings Logan down to the arcade, but before
she can kill him, he is informed of another
runner. They two get into a vehicle and chase the
runner. They end up in an area filled with “cubs”,
people who are deemed unfit to live in the main
complex because of their wild nature. The cubs
circle the two, intending to rob and kill them.
But Logan uses his weapon to chase them away.
Next, Logan uses his scanner to scan the
area and locate the runner they were looking
for. He finds her within seconds but instead of
arresting her, he lets her go out of sympathy.
Because of this, Jessica drops her plan
to kill him and starts to believe he is
genuinely a good person. As the two continue
their journey to the Sanctuary, we see Francis
kill the runner they just spared. He now has seen
Logan and Jessica get out of the cube’s zone.
Knowing that the sandman will eventually catch
him, Logan goes to a medical professional to get a
facelift to disguise himself. However, during the
procedure, the doctor gets a call from the sandmen
and turns against Logan. He pushes some buttons
and uses his face lifting device to attack him.
Logan reacts quickly and manages to avoid the
machine’s attack. Francis arrives at the clinic
and gets into a fight with him but Logan
and Jessica somehow manage to escape. Then,
they run to a tunnel and meet the other runners
on their way. Jessica’s friends do not trust
Logan because a Sandman turning into a runner
is unheard of. But they agree to let them go on
when a nurse from the clinic earlier
confirms that Logan is on their side.
The two are told to follow the tunnel to
reach the Sanctuary. Right then, a group of
Sandmen arrives with their guns blazing. The duo
manages to run away but is followed by Francis.
They eventually reach a door that requires the
ankh to open it. Jessica tries to get hers from
her necklace but it falls into the water and
gets lost. Logan quickly uses his one to open
the door and go to the other side. When Francis
comes following them, he finds Jessica’s ankh
and continues the pursuit. Meanwhile, the duo is
lifted up by a machine to a frozen cave. They are
approached by an AI robot called the Box, whose
job is to capture food from the outside world to
feed the city. The robot is about to freeze them
into food but Logan uses his gun to fight him.
Eventually, the cave starts to fall apart and
the two run into the outside world. They are
mesmerized by the beautiful scenery in front
of them. They have been so brainwashed by the
computers that they don’t even know what the sun
is and call it a “hot ball”. After walking for a
while they sit down to take a rest, unknown that
Francis has followed them outside as well.
The next day, Jessica and Logan are tired of
walking and are still looking for the Sanctuary.
They eventually reach a pond and decide to take a
swim. Jessica finally gives into Logan’s efforts
and the two make out. They also see that
Logan’s life clock has stopped flickering,
meaning that the clock doesn’t work in the outside
world, and they can live for as long as they want.
Later that day, they notice a tower and happily
approach it, thinking it is the sanctuary. But
they are soon met with disappointment to see
the tower and the buildings around it have
been taken over by nature. Suddenly, a cat
brushes over Jessica’s leg, startling her.
The couple is fascinated to see an animal for the
first time. They follow it and reach a classroom
with an old man inside. They both are amazed by
his wrinkles and grey hair as they have never
seen a person that old in the city. The man says
that he has been living there since the holocaust
and didn’t even know that the city existed.
The duo also learns that the old man was raised
by his parents, unlike the residents from the
city who are made in a laboratory and raised in a
nursery. Suddenly, Francis arrives there and holds
Jessica hostage. Holding her at gunpoint, he asks
Logan to get closer so he could terminate him. But
Logan manages to divert his attention by asking
him to look at his palm. Francis is as surprised
as the others to see his life clock not blinking.
But even then, he doesn’t want to believe he has
been lied to his whole life. He attacks Logan
and the two get into a fight. The struggle ends
when Logan manages to wound Francis gravely by
hitting him with a pole. Logan then holds his old
friend in his arms and wishes him goodbye as he
dies. Following that, the old man makes the couple
bury Francis’s body in a grave. He claims that he
buried his parents around the same area because
that is what humans are supposed to do.
Logan wants to go back to the city to show
the people there is so much more to life than
artificial lighting and dying at thirty. He thinks
that the residents will believe him if he shows
them the old man as proof. The next day, the three
of them leave for the city. While resting on the
way, the old man explains the concept of marriage
and family to them. They eventually reach a hydro
plant that supplies water to the city. Logan asks
the old man to wait for them for as long as he can
before the couple jumps into the water and swims
back to the city. Logan finally tells the people
about the outside world, but no one cares. The
only people who hear them are the sandmen who
arrest them. Logan is taken to an interrogation
room where the computer asks him if he found the
Sanctuary. When he doesn’t answer, they use a
technique called surrogation to look into his
subconsciousness and download data from his mind.
However, the vast knowledge of the outside world
is too much information for the computer to
process and it starts to malfunction.
Everything controlled by the computer starts
to explode, including the facility they are in.
The city is ruined, making the people run
outside in fear. As the domes are destroyed,
the people are introduced to the outside world
for the first time. They see the old man and
are amazed by his wrinkles like Jessica was. They
surround him, asking if they can touch his skin.
The movie ends as Jessica and Logan
wave at the man from the crowd,
indicating a happy ending.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.